[Music]
to our other top story tonight a couple
visiting from New Mexico killed in a
hit-and-run crash in downtown on Fremont
Street and in only on eight special
tonight the family of the victims
speaking about the impact of this deadly
event Madison Kimbrough joins us live
where that crash happened on Fremont
tonight with more Madison
while we did reach out to the family to
speak they did not want their sound on
camera or to be on camera but they did
share some words about this tragedy the
tragedy that happened right here near
Fremont Street now both Christy and her
husband William Baxter were visiting Las
Vegas from New Mexico when they were
struck by a drunk driver Wednesday night
December 28th the couple who was
visiting for the holidays attempted to
cross 4th Street near the Fremont Street
Experience against a don't cross
pedestrian signal when an SUV hit both
Christy and William and then took off
Christy and William originally from
Texas were married for 10 years Christy
leaves behind three children and her
mother Susie now in a statement their
family released to eight news now they
shared that both Christy and William
strive to help anyone and everyone who
crossed their paths stating that quote
this tragic horrible death has affected
many and they will be dearly missed they
were loved and cherished police said the
driver of the SUV Mikhail Terrell was
traveling Northbound on a green signal
on 4th Street when she struck the
pedestrians and fled the scene Witnesses
and video from the scene helped police
identify the driver as the suspect in
the case now Terrell was located and
arrested for DUI and hit-and-run charges
William was pronounced dead on scene
while Christy was taken to UMC where she
later died now currently the family is
in Las Vegas picking up the family's
things as well as talking to police
about this horrific event reporting near
4th and Fremont Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now